bom após aqui que muitos de vocês já com
dificuldades e até ela é o que ela é
nós não sabemos por que então essa é uma
coisa que vejo jovens até 11 meses
só que se escolher o que quer dizer que
a vida é encantadora e ela pode ser
gratificante quando a gente usa para
conseguir lugar
então pode ser
a qual esta ópera cosi como eu disse
sobre na esfera cível
em casa somos quatro meninas e meninos
e não é porque eu sou eu ela tem essa
recente teve um compacto dos cachos e
assinou contrato de fazer nada diz meu
país dia ela existia também quer dizer
em pleno ano da sua criação das crianças
mais novas e mais equipadas com cadeiras
e da junta um dos momentos depois de
algum tempo internado há algum tempo
paralisada
eu vim da casa usando aparelho e muletas
e aí nós lá no sítio por uma geralmente
um tapa na bola nos últimos dias frios
faço tudo está em todos os homens
passado todas as linhas
só quero que aconteça que tinha 15 anos
que tal não se paute momento de dor de
ler e de remessa de muitas alegrias de
muito pensar de muitas coisas boas
porque quando mal pra casa
a cirurgia só jesus levantou comigo uma
música que eu tinha pedido no domingo é
linda como estava pessoas não conhece
pessoas interessantes
pessoas que é a doença também poucas
vezes a ver comigo
a raiva de profissionais que achavam que
a dor era coisa de criança
a diferença é que nesta hora da manhã o
que acontece então essa vivência
pronunciou uma experiência que foi muito
significativa
com ela aprendi a ser mais forte e
grande diferencial isso né eu sabia nem
sabia algumas coisas então já então que
as filhas mas é uma antena de estudar
teologia espiritual se eu quisesse eu
tivesse algum interesse trabalhar um dia
vai pensando nisso e aí meu pai saiu do
sítio e fomos pra cidade vizinha cidade
é de ir à cidade
os estudos da cidade de nápoles em meu
pai por exemplo que nenhum ser bastante
trabalho à cidade andar porque quando eu
salão a presença de uma grande roda 15
anos eu passei a lutar na venda de notas
mas para além das grelhas também feita
de ganhos né de ter origem a um ensino
médio surgiu de psicologia
hoje a gente botou lenha vamos para
londrina em londrina
de short stack uma cidade muito pequena
como jardim alegre pra ir a londres
e aí eu falei vou fazer psicologia vou
tentar estudar em casa e aí escolar
sei o que passei no vestibular e agora
pergunta é a seguinte como é que você
vai fazer pra ele pergunta se a minha
mãe e ela também é em 1100 mãe a gente
dá um jeito a gente tem não sei
imagine um adaptado
acredito que não né
um dia um sábado de ônibus circular que
estava em jogo disse
de qualquer forma então é como nós
fazemos a faculdade todos os dias de
manhã e à tarde
assim vamos fazer uma viagem pode falar
com a mãe
em seguida ela é colocada no ônibus e
uma mochila quando nem bonita copa que a
mochila pensa em uma mochila na mochila
de um estudante universitário primeiro
ano de psicologia 2º 3º 4º e 5º né
aí ela voltava fechava a cadeira de
rodas né colocar a cadeira perto de mim
voltava e passava pela roleta
ok já fazia isso rapidamente minha mãe
ficou excelente isso nela realmente um
minuto ou menos de um minuto ela fazia
tudo isso pra voltar pra sair né era o
contrário do processo inverso a mãe
tirava a primeira cadeira abrir a
cadeira de roda
voltava para me pegar gente voltar para
me pegar
só que o que acontece em muitas ocasiões
na hora que ela descia com a cadeira
ônibus cheio lotados dantes né
o motorista embora e aí passamos nós a
roteirista motorista para eu vou descer
e aí às vezes minha voz imagine lá no
fundo
aí o pessoal começava a gritar para o
motorista também motorista calma ainda
não desceram todos também acontecer a
ele parava e amanhã atrás né
lindo com a cadeira me buscar e isso
aconteceu uma duas várias vezes durante
os cinco anos de curso não foi apenas
uma vez nesta uma cena constante no
começo a gente achou estranho a gente
ficava nervosa depois de estabilizada
depois a gente está acostumado a gente
já sabia que tudo ia dar certo não só
vai se preocupar né
foram cinco anos assim né apesar das
dificuldades em concluir o curso eu fiz
a o que eu desejava
ok até aí beleza e agora é esse fato em
abril um mundo de possibilidades
o mundo de possibilidades sempre
esbarrou na questão como é que eu vou
fazer pra ele porque a gente trabalha
como é que eu vou fazer para trabalhar
como é que eu vou fazer para chegar até
o local de trabalho
como é que eu vou fazer pra fazer pós
graduação essa sempre foi a pergunta
central
e aí nós voltamos pra jardim alegre
depois da faculdade e aí eu comecei a
trabalhar na escola de educação especial
a mãe levava também e eu voltava sozinha
ela decida em cima da produção ajuda né
eu comecei a trabalhar numa faculdade na
cidade vizinha eu fiz pós-graduação em
outras cidades inclusive eu saía de
jardim e para londrina para fazer pós
graduação
mas o grande desafio aquele que eu digo
mas como é que eu vou fazer agora e que
foi de fato definidor foi visto a menina
vai passar no mestrado na lei e tem que
decidir como é que eu ia fazer pra vir
pra cá porque não tinha nenhum parente
aqui em
em maringá há 13 anos atrás eu não sabia
nada sobre a cidade de maringá
mas eu disse eu vou eu passei no
mestrado é uma chance eu vou e fim e
esse vício me abriu um outro universo
uma outra vida porque a partir desse
momento eu comecei até que fazer e ter
que lutar sozinha tinha mais mãe
e aí eu comecei a ajudar a fazer o
mestrado
logo em seguida eu comecei a dar aula na
lei
e aí eu consegui também comprar uma
cadeira motorizada e a partir disso eu
me tornei uma pessoa extremamente
independente
eu era dona agora da minha vida eu não
precisava mais de ninguém para me levar
empregos a já tinha resolvido o problema
de como ir na cadeira de rodas e levava
né
e aí quando fui fazer depois do mestrado
fazer o curso de filosofia eu não mais
me perguntei como eu ia eu já estava lá
estava não é ea mãe também não perguntou
mais já estava lá né
o que significa tudo isso porque estou
falando isso porque eu acredito que o
grande desafio que nós temos é o de
ressignificar os equívocos da vida as
dores transformando as em aliadas né
fazendo delas possibilidades fazer com
que a gente tenha possibilidades e
oportunidades né e então esse foi sempre
o meu ponto e sempre foi a minha atitude
eu preciso estar na situação eu preciso
e garantir primeiro alguma coisa no
sentido de a vaga ser uma vaga precisa
garantir a vaga e depois da situação eu
vejo como faço vejo como a gente resolve
é isso que me trouxe até aqui
isso significa que é essa essa
perspectiva inclusive tem fez com que eu
vi no olhar das pessoas uma diferença
também hoje
antigamente eu vi no olhar das pessoas
um sentimento de pena olhava parecia me
que ela estava olhando pra mim pena isso
me incomodava isso
não me agradava de maneira alguma hoje
eu vejo o olhar das pessoas mais um
olhar de curiosidade principalmente
quando eu digo que eu sou independente
que mora sozinha que eu tenho há um
único membro única parte do meu corpo
não foi afetado pela pólio é o braço
direito
então a gente valorize o seu braço
eu sei o quanto ele é indispensável em e
significa também que a gente precisa
olhar as coisas de um modo mais natural
não existe aqui não ter nascido de olhos
azuis não foi notificado pelo contrário
eu adoro meus olhos castanho que acho
que eles manifestam o brilho alegria a
satisfação a gratidão que tenho pela
vida ter a pólio também não foi um
equívoco
faz parte da natureza faz parte da vida
nós não podemos ver deficiência como um
erro com uma falha como um castigo não é
faz parte da linha 300 são
possibilidades que a linha não tem ou
nos dar como a gente vai fazer com essas
possibilidades aí é nossa
responsabilidade mas não é não são
falhas elas não podem ser condenados à
china em transação pode ser consumido
considerado temos então nesse ano nesse
aspecto
a questão é se colocar se mover se é
propor a tentar ousar né isso que eu
sempre fiz
tentei usei né isso é interessante
quando me convidaram para participar
desse evento eu não tinha noção do
tamanho da magnitude que estou sendo
sincero com vocês eu não sabia gente eu
não sabia mas aceitei o convite
aí até falei mas e fria que você não
estuda me colocar
mas isso fez com que eu também descobri
se novas possibilidades sobre a mesma e
é enriquecedor
é gratificante compartilhar com vocês
então a idéia
deixo é exatamente isso 11
tente não tem medo não tem receio de o
primeiro passo o resto os passos
seguintes a vida se encarrega ela nos
propicia condições pra seguir em frente
eu sei que estou falando